this BuzzFeed hey Buzz today you'll be
taking a buzzfeed character quiz to find
out which girl character you actually
are hell yeah hi I'm Ang oh wait which
one do I look at one second one second
oh we're all good that's okay Queen oh
my nipples and you're watching I'm Ying
I'm sorry just tell me when you're done
oh Fu I'm good you done yeah I'm done
okay sleep with one eye
open I always do I'm angal rice I'm
Renee rice I'm jackwell Spivey I'm Chris
Bry I'm avanta I'm BB wood I'm Al
carvalo we are the cast of Mean Girls
And we are with BuzzFeed to figure out
which character we actually are
mhm thank you
propon got a budget I know that's
right I want to play wa don't look at
the questions and C what right there
wait I'm looking at it do you want to do
that first one yeah this means a lot to
first choose a song to sing at karaoke
get him back by Olivia Rodrigo is it
over Now by Taylor Swift ICU by Coco
Jones so good not strong enough by boy
Genius dial drunk by Noah Kahan and cuff
it by
Beyonce I feel like some answers here
are obvious not strong enough I listened
to every single morning on the way to
set while we were filming really yes
really so I'm going to choose that one I
See You by Coco absolutely you can't put
Coco and Beyonce in the same thing for
me to pick from that's religious don't
do that to me I mean the problem is like
I don't know basically most of these
songs so I love cuff it it's just like
why would I ever dare singing that's
exactly my thought I am choosing that
song Beyonce is my favorite of all time
but like I don't know I feel like I'm
shooting myself in the foot by picking
that so I'm going to go like maybe get
him back could someone hum dial drunk by
no Kahan
um that's what what radio do I listen to
what did you pick oh it's coffee yeah
yeah I got what do you I did boy Genius
there was no don't sing option
oh I'm going I seeu because if I'm going
to sing something by Beyonce which odds
are I will it wouldn't be cuff it that's
like I'm shaking my ass I don't want to
it would be Love on Top which Renee has
an iconic
cover that's such a good video I was
pretty drunk in that all right next pick
a 2000 movie to watch with friends 13
Going on 30 National treasure Peter Pan
A Cinderella Story Twilight or How to
Lose a Guy in 10 Days these are all so
good too good but I have to stay true
with Twilight I'm Sor Peter Pan is like
maybe one of the most important movies
it's like integral to my lore that movie
is amazing I've chosen National Treasure
on C medicine I watched both National
Treasures it was the best movie to watch
while see wait maybe I need to see it I
haven't seen a bunch of these well
choose choose one that you have seen you
pick National Treasure it's good I agree
you know it's not a competition yeah
what do you choose National Char to win
oh it's definitely a Cinderella Story
yeah I trying to let everybody get their
you know I think there's only one option
wait cuz waiting for you is like waiting
for rain in this
drought it's so good I chose How to Lose
a Guy in 10 Days it's also very good I'm
going with Twilight what is ever
collection no it's the credit for the
for the
photo and it's just IM now just choose
something Pink choose a pink pink Negron
it looks like I don't know what that is
yeah talk your sunet hot air
balloon I think some flowers and then
the burn book I'm going burnbook I'm
going the I'm going Sunset it's
something about an alcoholic beverage I
was no have you ever been to like
syndicated in Brooklyn the movie theater
oh no no they have this they have this
like hibiscus spicy Margarita okay look
kind of like that and it slaps even more
reason pressive am I the only one
choosing the hot pink heel right now I
had to weather them shoot that's why I'm
not picking them which Mean Girls adult
would you perform at the winter talent
show with oh John Ham I have a huge
crush on him wait read out read out the
options read out the options how you end
up on YouTube sorry I'm watching the
trailer okay so our options are I got
Miss Haron Katie's mama Miss norberry
Mrs George Madame Park Mr Duval and
Coach car now Damian already performs
with Miss norberry cuz she's on the key
yeah so for me believe Tim Meadows can
sing and sing well so I would actually
love to have a duet with Mr Duval I'm
going to choose Mother m Heron I feel
like she would have like some poetry she
could recite or something some beautiful
interpretive dance like I think she's
you guys you guys would do like aerial
silks together or some so it would be
something like that oh my God come on
and you would knit in the air yes I see
it I see it clear as D I'm also choosing
Tim I think because during icy Stars we
would do these like sort of Variety Show
Bits up on stage together and there was
like there was something there like we
need to maybe have like our own variety
show or something so I'm going to go Mr
dual I'm going to do Mr norberry I just
like align with her Chris who who do you
want to sing with trouble sh bro you
know I wouldn't sing you literally just
sang oper outside stop ly to everyone no
no no no no no
no in this scenario I'm performing at
the winter talent show what am I doing I
a magic trigger
too and like who would help me out I'm
think coach car would absolutely of
course and of course you would try to
take John Ham from me I've met him so oh
okay and and maybe I will you'll get
there maybe I maybe I'll get there he's
so hot I can't talk to that boy who
wants to read the next one okay nope I
can never no no do it do do it oh no I
would I literally would just I would die
go ahead okay pick a musical that's
based on a movie
Rouge got
read got hairspray Heather's the musical
Mulan Rouge once waitress Billy Elliot
the Musical my God wait so we're
choosing the musical not the movie cuz
my answer would be different a music
wait musical that's Bas my my choice is
Billy Elliot and these are all based off
a movie Yes waitress is based off a
movie yeah yeah oh my God wait of
course she's not real I'm making that up
I'm a big Barrett stand so Heather's the
music world I was in it in like
Community
Theater
Ensemble yeah but nobody heard me I did
it
quiet they just said mou the words I'm
choosing once that's like another thing
that I think is integral to my lore
really I'm sorry I don't even know why I
said like really I've never seen the
movie I've never seen the musical so I
don't even know where that came from
from me and I'm so sorry what are you
choing okay I forgive you I'm choosing
waitress what you I'm choosing waitress
waitress Zella pushed that pen so I I
mean if we're talking about the musical
Now movie musical Hairspray no
competition comp which one which one the
one
movie haven't been been live a couple
times would you count that I don't count
that no but yeah waitress z z yeah and
finally oh no you read it babe oh no I
just got excited oh go ahead and finally
choose an actor from the original Mingos
to star in a movie with Rachel McAdams
Lindy Lohan Amanda cyer is that how you
saying sea C cyer it's fine you're
Australian it's adorable C Lizzy Kaplan
so hot Lacy shabar or Amy po who would
you pick Rachel mad M oh oh oh it
revealed my answer oh um oh it will come
as a shock to everyone to hear that I
will also be picking Rachel McAdams it
is also a film where we Star as lovers
fine I'll pitch it
this is a hot picture of her too I've
been revealed I'm going Amy polar so
nice so sick strong Choice they're all
strong Choice Chris M it was between
Amanda and Amy for me and I went Amanda
Amanda I chose Lizzie I'm stuck cuz I
could say Amy polar of course but I
could say Lacy because you know she' be
eating them Christmas movies up and I
would love to
live and be like we got to save the town
for Christmas I'm say Amy polar I'm
going to say Amy okay I think I have to
has everyone revealed I'm revealed as
hell you'll never guess who I am who did
you get Katie wait I did too and I did
too what Katie heren your personality
I'm so sorry damn cuz I'm seeing it so I
do have to say it my personality marches
Katie you're openhearted smart and
resourceful fact fact fact like Katie
you're someone who makes friends with
everyone not a fact which is often seen
as a strength unless you know you get
caught up in the popular crowd oo you're
someone who loves to explore the world
around you and you love experiencing as
many different things as possible that's
not right that's a picture of me you
look very cute look so cute I expected
to get Katie I knew I would get Katie
I'm disappointed in myself wait
no just like was I being true to who I
am who did you want to be Renee I always
want to be Rachel mad okay what did
everybody else get wait I got Katy here
and I'm so
excited I got
George sexy you're confident cunning and
charismatic I don't know like Regina
you're often seen as the leader of your
friend group you can make a decision and
once you know what you want nothing will
stop you from getting it some are
intimidated by you but you know your
strong will is your greatest strength
and that's Renee rap right there
withes shout out to BuzzFeed I got
Karen your personality matches Karen
you're spontaneous
imaginative and
intuitive like Karen people often
underestimate you but you're actually
the one who is always looking at the
bigger picture you're someone who
prefers to just do something and see
what happens instead of following a plan
your charm is one of your greatest
strengths I got Gretchen
Wieners you're optimistic kind and
reliable like Gretchen you're someone
who loves to be in the know which means
you often gravitate toward the popular
crowd you have a kind heart and often
need that little extra push to feel
comfortable speaking your mind I don't
resonate with that because I talk a lot
speak but I think I speak my mind but I
do feel like I'd probably be gret and
wieners this makes sense for me I got
Janice of course jice you're witty
artistic and courageous like jennice
you're someone who is fiercely
protective of the people closest to you
especially your best friends you're not
afraid to stand up for what you believe
in and share your honest opinion no one
got Damian no one could ever un match
but it
does so thank you so much BuzzFeed make
sure to check out me and girls in
theaters on January
[Music]
12th